welcome everybody Welcome to my talk
about turning groelvium from a research
into a product I'm Thomas I'm from
Switzerland
I was growing up in a small village in
Austria somewhere in the middle of
Europe and
when I was studying at University I was
super lucky to be offered an internship
at a big American company with a great
history called Sun Microsystems
yeah and at some Labs actually it's not
Microsystems Laboratories this is where
you know even the the Java programming
language was started there and
so I was super excited I was like yes
this is my chance finally Silicon Valley
America you know
endless opportunities endless
opportunities so I was I was I was
working really hard there and um
yeah and so then later we and I started
to work on compilers and and virtual
machines back then it was a research
virtual machine called a Maxine VM
and then later I got back to my studies
and finished my studies and I started
working at the
Oracle which by then was has bought the
assigned Microsystems but continue
working with my colleagues and I started
in a small like research setting but I
was really like very confident because
it was like well just out of credit
school you know others University I was
like let's let's go and so so the first
thing really for me was and I think this
is still very important when you are
starting something at the beginning you
got to be really bold and foolish like
you got to be like yeah otherwise
otherwise your idea or what you would
try to do might might be too you know
not not kind of you know big enough so
at the beginning we were kind of
ignorant about the potential problems we
would face and we're very confident so
we published a research paper and uh we
called it
one VM to rule them all
so um as you can see here me and my
colleague Christian Wimmer we were
already working at Oracle Labs at the
research Labs the other people here on
the team
um were still at University because
they're like kind of students and you
really we were like driven by the vision
to create one virtual machine to rule
all languages
because I was working at some
Microsystems at the job working machine
I was working at Google at the
JavaScript V8 engine as well and I felt
like there's all this duplicative work
like there's like a lot of things that
are in common between a JavaScript
virtual machine and a Java virtual
machine and why don't we build one
virtual machine for all languages
so this is how the the project got like
um off the ground and the initial
version was named by us c1x for Hotspot
which well if not for a more uh you know
a little bit more experienced colleague
of of ours Mario volsko uh he said he
told us like yeah this this sounds like
really funny like you shouldn't do that
so so that's when we like then uh found
out yeah you know a good name would be
great as well and we called it gra
because we were like in Pursuit for the
for the best answer and and the the the
the crawl of the
and and so that that's why then the
project crowd really got its name and
and got started
now there was a lot of talks about
careers at the first keynote today I
found it very inspirational and so I I
thought you know I add one slide here
which is uh my career at Oracle then and
there is one thing I would say about
that is like to me the career felt a
little bit like being a frog getting
boiled
so you know
you start as an engineer you know life
is happy you you write your programs and
then you kind of you have to lead a team
at some point and you kind of get
promoted as a senior engineer and then
you get to manager you get the director
and and so on and so forth right and
with each step you you feel like things
get a little worse
because you know the thing is like as
you as you go upwards like it's like
you get more and more problems and you
get less and less opportunities and
solutions and people like playing your
first things and people are not
necessarily like giving you you know
compliments or anything like that and
also when I was you know when I was a
little bit more like um
let's say it was still fun to lead a
small team you know it's meet a team of
you know five people maybe 10 people so
you know everybody you can work with
them you have still a personal
relationship with them so that's still
pretty fun but then when you go then
upwards you know to like 30 people 50
people 100 people it's like you you
really have to work hard not to lose the
connection to your people because it
really is the danger that your people
become like an entry in an actual
spreadsheet basically and uh it's it's
um
and and so so this is something I'm I've
been uh for sure kind of struggling with
to to maintain this spirit
of our early days when you were small
right but of course
the reason why I still think it was
important for me to like you know go in
this direction is that you also don't
want when you want to grow your project
and you want to like then at some point
ship it and have it large scale and in
production and on all the platforms and
supported and 10 different versions and
so on you need a lot more people than
initially like the initial research
prototype you can build with with a few
of your colleagues but but as you grow
there needs to be a lot more people
involved right and you also don't really
want to kind of the project is still
sort of like you feel like it's your
baby and you don't want to like get it
like be done by somebody else so you
feel like a certain responsibility that
you kind of
and you can also ask you know like why
why the hell are you 12 years at the
same company like what's what's
happening and um my one thing here is in
Europe This is actually more common
like Europeans feel like well there's a
you know I'm at the company I'm staying
there I'm feeling some loyalty
um now another reason of course is that
I was lucky enough to be allowed at
Oracle to build up my own team so I
could hire my people like everybody on
the team is hired by me and then it's
kind of difficult for me to go to a
different job because I have to leave my
family right
so so I'm like uh so in that sense like
um yeah it was it was very
um this is one of the reasons why I
think um
it's actually not easy if you're in
certain positions here to to change a
company or to go somewhere else right
now one other aspect here and this is
what I'm actually grateful for Oracle to
a lot is that Oracle is a company that
sinks here long term as you can see here
we started the project 12 years ago
and we just you know one or two years
ago got our first you know paying
customers
so we had a almost 10 years room where
we were working and getting financed
from Oracle without an Roi and if you
would have tried that as a startup or
you know some smaller company it would
have been much much harder to to justify
this level of investment and in the
virtual machine and compiler space this
level of investment is is necessary
because of the complexities involved and
how long it takes until a technology
gets adopted and I feel this craviem as
a virtual machine and technology for
language execution we are still at the
very early stages of adoption so it will
still take another five years another 10
years for this to become real mainstream
now one other lesson I think that that
we learned and there was kind of
interestingly project is that
constraints really Force creativity and
innovation
and I I like to tell a story on the
project about that
so early in the project well we did this
Java virtual machine which makes sense
because Sun Microsystems and later
Oracle have the child virtue machine
but I really personally wanted to also
go public cloud and compete with
JavaScript engines I wanted to show that
you can build one virtual machine with
multiple languages
and I also wanted to compete of course
it's my old team the VA team at Google
so I felt a certain competitiveness so I
can also execute JavaScript on my
compiler
and so we tried various approaches and
tried to make a JavaScript specific
front-end for our Java compiler so we
try to translate JavaScript into Java
but you kind of got stuck in the
complexities of doing that
and the main problem for us also was
like we had no budget
because I was going to a management and
said you know I want to you know I want
to build this also this JavaScript thing
here and management said you know there
is no money in JavaScript engines
uh
yeah find something else
and uh I'll do more of this Java stuff
right so so now we didn't have budget
available but we really really wanted to
do it
so we we needed to find a way how to
like circumvent that and the good thing
is we had this University collaborations
and they were
um well like Oracle has a collaboration
with University in Austria and we had a
little bit of extra budget not a lot but
enough
to fund a master student for half a year
part-time
so we found an unsuspecting part-time
Master student
who was willing to take on that project
of executing JavaScript on our virtual
machine
and we really didn't have much time or
effort to to get there at least to the
first prototype so we could convince
management that they should continue
maybe with a little bit of more funding
and what they came up with was the the
primary research contribution we feel
that came out of the project and was
really in this situation where I was
like I really want to do this but I only
have half-time Master student that
forced me to come up with the solution
that's simpler and better than what's
currently there
if I had like the full budget then I
could you know have a small team I would
have not gone for the best solution
and this solution is what we call
ingravian partial evaluation of
interpreters
so in claudium when we execute other
languages like JavaScript or python or R
and Ruby it's all languages that we
execute on us the way it works is that
we build an interpreter for these
languages
and then we do partial evaluation of
that interpreter into compiled code
automatically
and what this does for us is that the
compiler is not language specific so our
compiler knows nothing about JavaScript
knows nothing about python knows nothing
about Ruby
and all the specificity of a language is
built into The Interpreter for that
language
and building an interpretive file
language is relatively simple uh like
you can a master student a good Master
student can build a simple like a subset
of JavaScript interpreter in this time
frame and this got us to the point where
we could convince management well maybe
it's a good idea to continue along that
path
dear of course wanted us to put then the
JavaScript engine into the Oracle
database which is a challenge but it led
to the next innovation in the project
actually
but we later were publishing a paper
about this this is a practical partial
evaluation of height of performance
Dynamic language runtimes
and as you can see this is a lot of the
names on this paper are the same on
division paper except you all see now
the Oracle affiliation on them
so by now most of them have been
converted to employees
so
yeah and and so then like when we
initially did the project right we did a
lot of different things and we
envisioned a lot of different things
that you could do with our platform
and we really took sort of the approach
of like well throw stuff against the
wall and let's see what sticks
so we tried a lot of different things
and when we went really a big open
source launch the first time in 2018
we created a blog post which we called
the top 10 things
to do with gravian
and it listed all the different parts
that we think you could theoretically do
with our with our system and we were
lucky that this first initial launch it
kind of got viral on social media and so
we had a lot of eyes looking at these
things
and this was super useful for us because
now we got some external validation of
which of our ideas are maybe interesting
for other people and which are just in
our head interesting and not really
interesting for others
and I like to go through some of these
now and a little bit on which ones
didn't work out first
so we had the idea that people would
happily combine JavaScript Java Ruby and
r
and unfortunately that's really
interesting from a research perspective
but
um you know a lot of people told us that
I don't don't want to do that
and yeah there's there's challenges with
it and we thought yeah maybe some Legacy
code base wants to use two languages Etc
but no this this idea was very
interesting from a research perspective
we got our nice papers out of it but it
didn't like get anywhere
that also meant that tools working
across all languages
again
because you felt like well we have a
compiler for all languages I would why
shouldn't we also build tools for all
languages right but the problem is
developers in different language
communities have very different
preferences
and they are not willing to compromise
on anything for you know
that tool being also able to run the
other language right the other language
is probably rather the enemy you know
and
so so in that sense our tools that work
across we had a debugger for example
that you could use between different
languages you can even nowadays you can
still you can use the Chrome debugger to
not only debug JavaScript but also a
ruby code by the way uh it's I mean it
works but but it's it's still something
that didn't got a lot of traction
running native languages on the TVM was
an interesting idea it was kind of like
trying to make C C plus plus secure uh
we tried to interpret CC plus and uh
llvm Bitcoin in the end so everything
that compiles to llvm bitcoin could be
run
uh and it would actually run more secure
but again it was a small Niche and
people were didn't much care about it
the other problem we had is a footprint
and startup warm-up problem in this in
this project that was just in the end
too big
similarly extending a native application
with scravian wasn't really a thing
either people who write native code
don't want to combine with anything else
people write CC plus plus they don't
want a virtual machine in there so these
were all ideas we put into our blog post
that we thought would be interesting but
in the end didn't make it now
we have Java code as a native Library
it's something that also people are not
using a lot but it's something we used
internally
because as I said you know in order to
justify our project and the budget for
our project
we uh we were looking for ideas how can
you make this applicable in a product
that Oracle cares about right and Oracle
cares a lot about Oracle database
so
now the best thing if you're at the
large company is to be attached to the
best Flagship product right
and so we got attached to the flagship
product by selling okay we can run our
thing in the Oracle database
but in order to run it there we needed
to Now link with native code because the
Oracle database is written in C
and so this is what got us in the
project started with this translation of
ahead of time compilation from java to
native code
and we use it very extensively in our
project and this is what later I will
later talk more about this because this
is the aspect of the project that in the
end got most traction externally
and it's funny here in the sense that
for us this wasn't the primary thing of
the project initially for us this was a
necessary thing we got to do to achieve
parts of the Project's goal maybe but we
we never thought this would be this
thing which other people would in the
end primarily
um be using from us
also so-so is creating your own language
you can grade your own language on top
of our system uh very easily and there
is some companies doing that but it's
it's it's still
um not not like super common
but
what was working okay was high
performance modern Java we had a better
cheat compiler for Java we still have a
better jit compiler for Java so you can
run Java applications faster
we got the polyglot story working by uh
by by this extending hivm based
application so in this setup you have a
Java system you have a Java application
then you want to extend it with
JavaScript always Ruby always r or with
python
specifically JavaScript on top of java
is something people would like to see
and we have a very large internal also
internal Oracle customer Oracle netsuite
is using this system to execute
JavaScript on top of their Java platform
polygon in the database also worked out
we got into the Oracle database we're
shipping in production with the Oracle
database at this stage and we are also
shipping in production with mySQL since
last week was announced actually this
week it was announced that Oracle
cloudwell that we're also in the mySQL
database so running languages in a
database was something that that also
was sort of working but this thing which
we in the end was the final like most
used aspect of the project was the low
footprint fast startup Java so this was
this thing where like we are
executing Java code and we are ahead of
time compiling it into a native binary
to make it start super fast make it low
footprint and make it a predictable
performance out of it
and
for us we put out this blog post in 2018
and then after one two years we saw this
feedback kind of flowing in and this was
for us and the trigger to make sure that
within our project we have the right
investment in the areas where we think
yes this is something users are actually
going to like and this is something
we'll build upon
now the polyglot part we really always
yeah we wanted to run all these
languages and
we still do and we still have a very
large teams uh writing um our JavaScript
engine we have a team riding a python
engine on top of our system
but so we have
the challenges that we underestimated
initially coming from the Java world is
that most programming languages actually
lack specification
and this was like something we we kind
of really underestimated because because
Java is probably one of the programming
languages with the best specification
out there
so in Java every version is very well
specified you have to Java language
specification you have to Java virtual
machine specification and
this is super important for the Java
ecosystem
because this allowed also for Java to
have actually multiple implementations
of the language
and what we try to do in some of these
language communities is really yeah try
to make sure that there can be multiple
implementations of the same language
because it enriches the community it
gives more choice to developers of that
language
and in Java one aspect which is also
well specified is the Java
native interface so how does Java
interact with CC Plus Code this is from
a document from 1997. back then it was a
company called javasoft a sun
microsystem business
and um Chang Liang was responsible for
writing the first he had a release 1.1
of the Java native interface
specification
and
I'm telling this here because if I look
now at a different language so let's say
python
and you go to
for python to the documentation on how
do I write a native extension for python
then it tells you okay yes you can write
your native
Native
CPC code and then what you should do is
you should include a header that's
called python.h
I mean it's that's that looks okay it
makes sense right so but let's now look
into like what is in that header
python.h
and then this is an on the right yeah
yeah the font is a little small uh but
this is an extract from it from GitHub
from python.h edit includes everything
in that interpreter foreign
now if you run that through a c
preprocessor to expand the method
definitions it looks a little bit like
this well there is pi module Pi add Pi C
ABS etc etc and there's 1 300 more
interest to this
here is your specification
so yeah so so this is some of the parts
we are struggling with most when we
Implement other languages and we have
the same problem with Ruby
when Ruby is essentially the same so
people and it's it's kind of yeah there
was the Ruby interpreter and people
started to just write native Extensions
by including the whole interpreter
and in this way you have no abstraction
between interpreter and the extensions
anymore and this only not makes it very
difficult to create an alternative
implementation it also makes it even
difficult to stay compatible as a native
extensions between versions of the same
implementation
because now suddenly all of this has
become your interface to the world and
if you change it you will break stuff
and this is why we have very happy
actually we're quite active in the
python community and this is where we
are active specifically on a project
that's called H Pi which is uh trying to
mitigate the situation by creating a
better C API for python so instead of
including python.hd will include h pi.h
which will be much more narrow in what
you can actually access from The
Interpreter and this will help
compatibility within the python
ecosystem also for sea Python and it's
helping us to implement python top of
the gravian system
yeah but but this is just one of the
aspects I think we underestimated in
terms of complexity when we are trying
to run other languages
now one lesson I think we learned over
there and and we learned it based on
user feedback in the end is that we
should really in now it is time with
with the cloud being so prevalent
consider that ahead of time compilation
is just better than just in time
compilation in many aspects
and I'm saying this is somebody who who
started his career working on a
just-in-time compiler and worked on
just-in-time compilers for the next 15
years 20 years and then yeah but when
you work very long on something you also
have a benefit that you know all the
disadvantages of this thing
so uh now maybe maybe I will later learn
about the disadvantages ahead of time
compilation once we do that for another
10 years but but in the end uh well
let's say both have a place but the
trade-offs are interesting and I think
it's it's interesting for a language
community in this case it's we're
working mostly with the Java Community
to provide an option for both
and this is what we do nowadays
primarily with scrollium where you can
run Java in just in time compile mode as
you usually run your Java program but
you can also run Java in an ahead of
time compile mode
and this is like looking more like you
compile a c plus program where you take
your Java program and then you create a
so-called native image it's how we call
these artifacts and then you can execute
them multiple times
and this is what gives Java now a
competitive setting in terms of startup
time
memory footprint and and so on that that
is typically one of the disadvantages of
using a heavyweight jvm
and this is interesting because what are
the important operational metrics when
you execute workloads in the cloud and
you care about the memory usage because
it's typically something you pay for the
more memory you use the the larger
instance you will have to allocate and
the more money it's going to cost you
you care about this throughput maybe you
care about the tail latency you care
about what is your your worst case
latency requirements and then you care
about startup warm-up sometimes you care
more about it when you're doing
serverless with Lambda for example AWS
Lambda Oracle functions then you care
more about startup warm-up maybe
sometimes you care less about it
and we have here now an example program
that is we take here the spring path
Clinic example which is the spring is
one of the most
um it's the most used Java Frameworks
for writing server server-side
applications nowadays and spring pet
clinic is their demo application where
they are modeling a pet clinic store
right
and
we have Benchmark this now and we
benchmarked it on on the jit compiler
against the head of time compilation
and we can see now the first question is
what's the memory footprint of that
application
and the answer is it depends
and on my first thing it depends on is
how much Max Heap setting do you give
your application
so for all these applications in Java
but also JavaScript there's now a big
there's not a big debate in JavaScript I
think between bun and node.js I believe
and then they are they're saying you
know how much memory mon uses versus the
other Etc right so the interesting part
is they're like
how much memory something uses depends a
lot on how much you configure the
Cabbage collector with
and here the graph where I've shown on
the x-axis different configurations for
the max Heap setting
and on the y-axis is the actual memory
used by the application
and you can see like
in in this range up to about 1.5
gigabyte it's if you give it smaller
memory the the gvm will just try to uh
the the the virtual machine will just
try to not use that and at some point uh
it doesn't need more anymore so even if
you provision more memory it doesn't
doesn't take more but another thing to
take away here is that the actual memory
used is often higher than your max Heap
size because when your max Heap size
configuration is only configuring
objects it doesn't configure metadata
so other things that gvm would would use
in terms of memory
and now I have the same graph on the so
I'm again checking all the different
configurations and I'm measuring this
peak throughput of this application
and this shows you now how memory is
traded against throughput typically so
you can the more memory I give the
application the higher is the throughput
and it's like in a little bit of a curve
which shows that there's a there's kind
of a sweet spot where well at this point
giving more memory to the application
doesn't help any much anymore
but this is like there's a point in the
curve which is optimal and I can
visualize that better by multiplying
those two things not together uh to come
to a metric which you call Operations
per gigabyte seconds
so how many operations can your program
do when running for one second using one
gigabyte
and we can see here that in this
scenario specifically the head of time
compilation has a much better trade-off
for you because it uses less memory for
almost the same throughput or in this
case it's even a slightly higher
throughput so the throughput is kind of
the same but you saving memory
and but this also shows you and for you
as a takeaway is that when you run these
virtual machines and the same is with
JavaScript virtual machine Etc
it depends a lot how you configure the
garbage collector
this can depend a lot your operational
efficiency and in this case it's 2x like
if I if I give it too much memory I have
a 2X verse operational efficiency
if I go in our studio operation metric
summary then
well my memory usage was 40 lower when I
use ahead of time compilation
my Peaks report is actually eight
percent higher in this case now some
people say well this cannot be the case
because cheat compilers are so smart and
they optimize better than the other time
compilation right now
the truth is a cheat compiler optimizes
an application based on how it behaves
in the first
seconds maybe first minutes
and then it's when it's created its
machine code it hardly ever actually
re-optimizes because re-optimizing costs
again time and observing whether you
need to re-optimize also costs time
which means you you you cannot in order
to later re-optimize you would have to
sacrifice some of your throughput
some of your time you have to sacrifice
right this is like a it's a it's a very
important property that this is just
theoretically not possible and now what
we what we do in ahead of time
compilation
is that we are creating profile guided
optimizations so you run your workload
on something that you care about
you got a profile and then you feed that
profile into your
run when you create your final binary
and this has of course a disadvantage
that we cannot react and you know maybe
your profile is off but it's also an
important Advantage which is
predictability so your profile is not
random based on what the app did in the
first startup period right and it also
gives you control over what the app
should optimize for
because otherwise a cheat compiler will
always optimize for the common case
but maybe if something uncommon happens
you don't want to be slow
typically actually in a cloud
environment where you want to reduce
your tail latency you want to optimize
for uncommon cases because when you
optimize for your worst case not for
your best case jit compiler always
optimizes for best case
and with ahead of time compilation in
PTO we can optimize for what you think
is should be optimized for
now this throughput per memory of course
is much higher as I showed because now
of course I get the similar or even
higher throughput but use much less
memory and T latency is lower because
there's less variability in the system
and the startup is of course much much
faster I mean we don't need to talk
about that right I mean that's that's
yeah that's that's the normal thing but
but what is what is kind of new since
since our last releases is that we have
caught up also in Peak Performance which
means that there is no more
operational disadvantage in terms of
running it at all and this is why we
think eot is better than cheat on all
operational metrics uh in this kind of
setting all right but uh yeah so that's
enough of the sales pitch uh thank you
very much so uh but it is it is it is
this has been like the main driver now
for our project this type of increased
operation metrics and this is important
also for sustainability because what
happens here is that you not only run
faster with lower memory but you also
consume less energy
and I'm just coming from Oracle Cloud
world where we're on on the keynote on
the Cloudy we're talking a lot about how
they try to reduce energy consumption
because it is projected that in about 10
20 years from now like a very large
portion of energy will go into Data
Centers
and so this operational efficiency is
also about reducing energy consumption
yeah
so now my final uh takeaway in section
is that well the ecosystem and early
adopters are really key to success
and this is so important for the project
and has been super important for us and
I'm super grateful for everybody who was
trying out our project at the point when
it wasn't yet ready
because you have to have somebody like
that because you have to get somebody to
get that feedback otherwise you're in
this Loop but like wow nobody's using my
stuff so I don't get feedbacks I can't
make it better so this is super
important and we try to put a lot of
emphasis and we're very happy that in
the Java ecosystem we have been working
with different framework authors for
example uh different uh libraries Etc
that are all working with us to uh to
make the system better
no our success brings a lot of fans also
some haters to be fair
now uh when you when you when you build
something like that at some point you
will always be on somebody's footsteps
at some point and and that will kind of
uh but I don't have anything on the
slide because they want to give them any
space
so
uh ecosystem adoption has been also good
in the Enterprise space for us by now
all major Cloud providers have announced
support for growing native image this is
AWS Google Cloud Microsoft Oracle all of
them and we have an open source project
cloud is an open source project there's
also a product associated with it so you
would it would be something that some
people will call it's a corporate open
source project uh that's true but it is
open source we have other distributions
Red Hat has a distribution and it's an
open source project with a business
model behind it which means that we have
the engineering power to maintain this
and it's a lot of commits go into this
thing we have four million lines of code
on GitHub for this
so despite the fact of course that some
people might say well that's not a pure
open source project there is a company
behind it yes I would say so but but
it's it's uh it has also benefits in
terms of like there's a sustainable
parts for this open source project and
it's very very big and maintain a lot of
code there
uh we encourage cooperation with other
people so if you're interested to work
with us or if your library wants to work
with us often we have people working
with us with with libraries or other
projects we are super happy to do that
because we want this driving ecosystem
and with this I would like to thank you
for your attention thank you very much
for your time I will be around at the
conference at the picture thank you